so let's say I have two functions that
are the inverse of each other so I have
f of X and then I also have G of X which
is equal to the inverse of f of X and f
of X would be the inverse of G of X as
well if the notion of an inverse
function is completely unfamiliar to you
I encourage you to review inverse
functions on Khan Academy now one of the
properties of inverse functions are that
if I were to take G of f of X G of f of
X where I could say the F inverse of f
of X that this is just going to be equal
to X and it comes straight out of what
an inverse of a function is if this is X
right over here the function f would map
to some value f of X so that's f of X
right over there
and then the function G or F inverse if
you input f of X into it it would take
you back it would take you back to X so
that would be F inverse or we're saying
G is the same thing as f inverse so all
of that so far is a review of inverse
functions but now we're going to apply a
little bit of calculus to it using the
chain rule and we're gonna get a pretty
interesting result what I want to do is
take the derivative of both sides of
this equation right over here so let's
apply the derivative operator DDX on the
left hand side d DX on the right hand
side and what are we going to get well
on the left hand side we would apply the
chain rule so this is going to be the
derivative of G with respect to f of X
so that's going to be G prime of f of X
G prime of f of X times the derivative
of f of X with respect to X so times F
prime of X and then that is going to be
equal to what well the derivative with
respect to X of X that's just equal to 1
and this is where we get our interesting
result all we did so far is we used
something we knew about inverse
functions and we'd use the chain rule to
take the derivative of the left hand
side but if you divide both sides by G
prime of f of X what are you going to
get you're going to get a relationship
between the derivative
function and the derivative of its
inverse so you get f prime of X is going
to be equal to one over all of this
business 1 over G prime of f of X G
prime of f of X and this is really neat
because if you know something about the
derivative of function you can then
start to figure out things about the
derivative of its inverse and we can
actually see this is true with some
classic functions so let's say that f of
X is equal to e to the X and so G of X
would be equal to the inverse of F so f
inverse which is what's the inverse of e
to the X well one way to think about it
is if you have Y is equal to e to the X
if you want the inverse you can swap the
variables and then solve for y again so
you'd get X is equal to e to the Y you
take the natural log of both sides you
get natural log of X is equal to Y so
the inverse of e to the X is natural log
of X and once again that's all review of
inverse functions if that's unfamiliar
review it on Khan Academy so if G of X
is going to be equal to the natural log
of X now let's see if this holds true
for these two functions well what does f
prime of X going to be well this is one
of those amazing results in calculus one
of these neat things about the number e
is that if the derivative of e to the X
is e to the X and in other videos we
also saw that the derivative of the
natural log of X is 1 over X so let's
see if this holds out so we should get a
result f prime of X e to the X should be
equal to 1 over G prime of f of X so G
prime of f of X so G prime is 1 over our
f of X and f of X is e to the X 1 over e
to the X is this indeed true yes it is 1
over 1 over e to the X is just going to
be e to the X so it all checks out and
you could do the other way because these
are inverse
of each other you could say G prime of X
is going to be equal to 1 over F prime
of G of X because they're inverses of
each other and actually what's really
neat about this is that you could
actually use this to get a sense of what
the derivative of an inverse function is
even going to be